we have a guest tonight but he's not
here yet he'll be here soon
okay but I wanted to start the podcast a
little earlier because I wanted to
address something last week was a very
difficult time for Tiger belly we had we
were on the front page I read it rage
with the first page of Reddit and we
also on the Chive and and and basically
what it was was people were lynching my
beautiful girlfriend kalaiy local local
as you know they were saying that she
number one she's not my wife get that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] right right now
is my [ __ ] girlfriend that's what it
address that part it makes me a non
skillful gold digger if I've been with
you for five years yeah and I don't have
a ring on my finger yeah I am the worst
gold digger so basically what it was was
they um they took a little tiny clip of
a podcast we did a long time ago and
basically kalila saying well what kind
of with your poor what kind of money
gonna throw out my tears basically what
it was right but it was but the context
of it was taken out of place because of
the fact that we were talking about you
after surgery how I wasn't emotionally
available and let me just say this and
and you can ask any girlfriend that I've
ever been with
it's a [ __ ] nightmare
to date me alright if it was just right
it's it's an absolute nightmare I mean
just it's admitted no one say something
all right I smell I have [ __ ] up feet
I have I have poor social you know
behaviors out there I have bad hygiene
I'm just disgusting I fart every 10
seconds I I'm just I'm dumb I don't
listen I don't know much about a
thing and I don't cuddle I'm not caring
it's it's I'm a difficult person today
okay and I'm telling you right now that
kalila I don't know what it is but
there's something about me that she
loves and that's what she's in it for
she's not in it for anything else I'm
telling you right now in fact she does
have a [ __ ] car right she has no
[ __ ] car this [ __ ] all right what
just let me talk that's a choice I
understand that but that's an understand
that but it's like you don't Virant
mentally conscious choice I had a car
when I met you
yeah I got rid of it I had a truck the
worst kind of car and I was like she
doesn't get anything from the
relationship all right she's losing in
life she's losing her soul yeah but any
five years wasted really five years of
her life wasted if you think about where
I was before I met you I had you know a
middle-class life right yeah I had a
home by the beach making I mean a job
what 80k a year maybe might not be a lot
to people but that's enough for a single
person like myself yeah I I had a nice
life I have you know college degree I
had pets good family good friends a nice
life
then an and a car even two bicycles a
skateboard and then she has to let my
gray dead alien dick and into her vagina
and that right there is you know I've
had to pay prostitutes more money
because they saw my dick and they said
no way no way thank you sir triple all
right I'm just not a catch you know and
it's kind of a nightmare for her it's a
what a nightmare so I know there's love
but my point is is this let me just say
this last thing is is that I didn't want
a [ __ ] address it because so dumb
that's even out there and at the end of
the day I know that you suffered greatly
it's it was a terrible thing I felt
really bad about it
people you know came to our defense
thank you yeah Tiger belly fans came to
our defense thank you but at the end of
the day and you're gonna hate to hear
this it's it's gonna pass I know that
it's gonna pass and you know the reason
why people are talking about it
at the end of the day is because we're
on the [ __ ] map and it's hard to say
that it almost felt like a personal
vendetta though there's a list of people
I know it could have been a short list
of people you guys are good at doing
that figure out who is yeah yeah but as
a matter of fact I'll give you a new
high Grappelli listener two thousand
dollars of my own money if you find IP
address of this and if you're able to
prove that it's this person who started
it I'll give you two K of my own already
know who you're talking about
it's getting crazy it is no it's not
interesting will you do Rath know not
what happens if you find the name I want
that person to be on our podcast also
you want okay there's a list find the IP
address to match it with who I think
they the original okay so there's
original I think that the original
version yes so let me let me get this
clear who posted it on reddit with that
title okay
yes but it's it's a one of five names
that's good that you narrow today okay
and no I don't think that it's that I
think it was probably just a [ __ ]
cheeto fingered little dick [ __ ] dude
there we go there's a rather angry but I
mean I think okay anything other than
like Vice have have is has there ever
been a true interview of a Cheeto fee
gorel right like I think that's pretty
interesting like hey what do you do all
day
why the hate why this but it's not just
that it's like what this cheeto fingered
I don't know what you two fingered me
somebody eats a lot of cheating as well
on cheeto fingered I love ya you with
Trump is he's cheeto fingers
he's very cheeto figuri about the whole
thing I also think that if you were a
white man that this wouldn't be a single
eye I don't think that this video would
have been pulled out with such like
interest from the pocket so here's the
theory the theory is this is that
because we we have contact we have rich
we know rich Asian dude that's married
to a beautiful white lady and his email
to us was basically it's a white dude
that dinner to desexualize me it's not
just one asian dude who wrote me there's
actually a lot of like asian men look at
me look at george he's upset did you
post it George you did you posted it for
the view you threatened by me yeah you
[ __ ] cops do you sexualized our cabin
shaving your beard you think shaving
your beard we know who you are and what
you look like you look foolish
clean-shaven by the way grow that beard
pronto in the box you had a chance now
no chance at what [ __ ] also people
people when you come to my shows in El
Paso just to want to say this don't go
to the don't go to the bodyguard or the
doorman go Jorge's a pink dick that's
that's not that's not a code to get back
to see me freaks them out the body are
the the bouncers don't know that code
they had only like pre they're not free
yes so when you just randomly walk up to
a big guy at a club and go he's George
is a pink dick they don't have the
context of so they think that either you
know me they know a guy named George
you're like what like the in the role
that probably
nor George or its gay it's a little like
you're hitting on me yeah you know so
just don't do that that's weird
um but I'm sorry that you went through
that baby it's okay to wrap this up
nicely to get the funny stuff out the
way first but on a serious note I always
appreciated our fan base always always I
always know that you guys are there
through our ups and downs but I was
never I've never been able to appreciate
them as much as I do now because of all
of this
yeah there's I've had so much support
male/female and it made me want to get
to know all of you even more I've never
felt so much love or there it is you
know you know slinky and also it's like
on this if Trent desexualize Papa you
can't do it it's like trying to
unspiritual eyes the Lord Wow the Lord
is pure spirit and I'm pure sex all
right who else comes up with terms like
no snow so that's a fire or science of
learned or a nobody okay yeah that was
uh who else can go into urban Bob don't
want no one okay I'm pure sex
you know III let me just say something
right now guys um I know how sexy I am
man I look in the mirror dude and I
[ __ ] I get half hard to gaff job yeah
I'm out damn that's look at my [ __ ]
Instagram me on top of the mountain
that's the king and I is that not right
that is so right so now Oliver is coming
so but we got that out of the way but
thank you so much Tiger belly fans we
love you so much
and we were gonna find this [ __ ]
[ __ ] that did this and we would
find him it's going to be a war against
like 14 no I don't give a [ __ ]
riot fingers cheeto fingered win again
and for the record
I've had two abortions if I wanted to
trap him I would have kept one of those
[ __ ] babies they're not gonna
they're not returned let's say you're
making an assumption babe they would
have been 16 hundreds on their SATs okay
maybe they will yeah but that's because
like of just pure falling on the
spectrum also by the by legislation to
this okay
by-the-bye listen to this okay this is
that I did this to my body choice all
right I look [ __ ] by choice when I
was a baby I was cute all right I ain't
throw out my whole life I was cute right
and what I did was I threw garbage and
sit inside my body and I lived this way
right to look like the way do I like the
way I look
I eat sugar cubes yeah I love sugar
cubes okay so I did this to myself but
if I wanted to look like Steven Yeun God
willing God willing I would please
please got to please guys anyway he's
coming
[Music]